you guys have roller skates I think we
have a pair around let me ask you a
question how fast do you think you have
to be going on roller skates you get
past a couple of armor guards and still
be going fast enough to smash through a
safe door one of those big Bank saves no
I don't know yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
it is so good to see you Keith yeah we
usually have to wait for a special
occasion well actually I have a little
surprise I got engaged son
yes
wow
congratulations little bro
engaged kind of a big deal more for me I
guess that's what that means
yes well um
she got a name Stephanie marriage is a
wonderful Journey 50 on the divorce
sorry bro them's just the facts
I will uh we'll keep that in mind thank
you
you got a photo oh yeah AKA does she
exist there you go
um
oh she's beautiful
let me get eyes on this
everybody else already huh
great lighting
yes airbrushed I know she kind of looks
like that one model uh on The Price is
Right uh yes
uh that's her The Price is Right Clive
that's your show shut up mom no it's not
uh yeah
Stephanie
people always under bid on their
showcases not the best presenter
where's the wedding oh uh in Hawaii oh
awesome
Mele Kalikimaka
she ever been married before uh no so
she says
ex-boyfriend she got one of course
sloppy seconds at least right Dad
she sounds wonderful
shut up mom Silence from you okay you're
cut off from talking
you know what Clive
I really don't appreciate the way that
you're talking to Mom
yes
yes
The Prodigal Son hath returned you know
what you want to go let's go cause I've
been here for the last 15 years taking
care of Mom and Dad well you've been
dropping all over the world and why so
you can come back here and criticize me
for how I treat them no
I actually came here
to ask you if you would do me the honor
of being my best man
[Music]
I know that we have a
had our differences
but you're my older brother
we'll pay for your room
and we're also going to rent you a car
and we'll pay to fly you out there
[Music]
first class
well we can't afford first class well
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you're dead to me
I'm eating my
camera
well that uh that went better than
expected
no is this good having another brother
move into the neighborhood hey man it's
good to have you over and I think that
you will dig this
you
hey
nice guitar collection oh thanks Manny
you want to hear something
yeah sure right
all
right
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red white and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue country music yeah I grew up in
Texas you know so all right keep her
safe from the homies in the wrong side
of town where they're smoking the reefer
and acting like
clowns keep that pretty wide dress from
getting dirty and brown cause that's the
American way
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
are black people black people but I'm
black
well keeping the red-headed girl away
from the homies on the wrong side of
town homies come on brother there's all
kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian homies
nah homies are black no I think you're
making them black man I mean I think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark God like is when I turn
off the lights the only Hood I love is
pointy and white tan trust you if I
can't see your face at night I think we
all know hey
[Music]
stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only Hood I love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the clan man
the Ku Klux Klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know I can't just say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like um Farrakhan on me right now oh my
God are you serious dude hey give me you
know can I do one more let me just do
one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far I'm not
hot
and find me a tree okay
foreign
come on man hey
you're trying to sing about a tire swing
right off an entire genre of music
[Music]
and the drums are a banging let's get
the boys together and have ourselves a
hanging oh damn now I see it
now I see it so you can say as much as
you want but you can't say the name of
the celebrity or any part of their name
got it yeah yeah we got it we got it
going down why don't you start the timer
and be amazed and go
okay this guy uh E equals m c squared
Albert Einstein yes that is correct
okay this is this is the uh the uh
determinator oh the uh
yeah let me talk about um uh are you
talking to me
[Applause]
pretend to be straight but he's really
gay
uh uh he is um excuse me he's living
living la vida loca
you say um
Latin Pop Star
I'm not a Latin Pop Star no you're not
it's not you
he bangs he bangs oh Ricky Martin
that is correct I wrote that one too
good evening my fellow Americans now
before we begin I'd like to once again
introduce you to my anger translator
Luther hi
now this November I want each and every
one of you to ask yourselves what has
changed in the last four years who
killed
what does my Administration accomplished
did we accomplish killing America's
biggest enemy uh check did that boom in
2011 alone we created more jobs than
George W bush did in all eight years of
his office except for Osama Bin Laden
Hunter because that job don't exist
anymore because I went over there and I
killed him in his face we helped make
Health Care accessible to more Americans
than ever before I'm sorry what'd you
say uh Your World Trade Center hurts
then why don't you take two dead bin
ladens and call me in the morning [ __ ]
this election make the decision that you
think best serves the future of this
country or
just vote for the person
I plan to run a Clean Campaign
one based on the issues and the
accomplishments of my Administration but
I'm gonna take you right now if the
Republicans if they get caught Osama Bin
Laden they wouldn't even pay him
actually man they just put a crown on
his head and give him a castle and it's
time to kill America and none of the yet
I said
straight up out of control brother well
uh it's not that bad okay don't beat
yourself up it's okay excuse me
no Luther you can't say that word oh
actually it says right here I can say it
whenever I want
I guess I can say it too
good night
come on
so I have finished the kitchen I have
finished my bedroom I have finished the
office and I'm just wrapping up the
living room okay I'll get a pack of
lacking I love it I love it I mind if I
put on some music I do not I do not I
got this new dubstep
what is that I don't know what that is
oh dude you're gonna love it oh cool
cool man
I like this okay for the drop I'm sorry
the drop
[Music]
what is happening
[Music]
what is that
the music I'm sorry is that music oh
yeah dude that's the dubstep man that's
my jam well it's it's a little uh loud
and disorienting and you know you're
being a little rough with my things dude
your stuff is fine why am I sweating so
much because you're feeling it is that a
good thing yes
come on man just give it another shot
okay okay I will
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa dude you're totally tracking my
flow up dude your nose is bleeding and
so is mine
awesome it doesn't really seem like
music to me
okay wow Wally getting a little bit old
no don't do that come on no didn't
realize that okay
um yeah what would you rather Listen to
I can hook you up with some Hootie and
the Blowfish if that's your oh that's
funny is that good color me bad you know
what go ahead I don't care I see what
you're doing go ahead and play it I
don't care because I'm not that old I
can get into it okay we just let's just
get this stuff packed play it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
friends
[Music]
do I look in the camera no oh at you all
right like on television all right
oh
now knock it off on a stupid ass grab
ass and touch it feel it Bulls God damn
I told you they was rotten
I am uh Partners Jackson uh principal
here at clortho
Vince clortho High uh this station is
just a formality there's a bunch of
stuff that we confiscated just this week
have to show them that here's a wand
with a silencer on it why but I ask
again why what other five girls in this
school is pregnant with a demon baby
the babies are evil but the mothers
they're good kids as we said chlorthos
there's never a portal that cannot be
opened with Ingenuity and respect
how you're going to be using an
invisible cloak when I can see you
tagging the damn wall dime bag of pixie
dust Contraband because here's the thing
the kids know that the only way to fly
wizard pepper unbelievable
get your ass out of my office I will
turn you into a spider
they're good kids Hogwarts and clothes
and Hogwarts go hand in hand the best
top two Wizarding schools there are but
you know uh out of these two schools we
each have our strikes we do score a
little bit lower on our standardized
tests than Hogwarts but there is a
cultural bias we may not have a huge
endowment like they get over at Hogwarts
and yes some of the teachers have to buy
their own new ties or bat wings one kid
got transformed into a cat they can't
even afford a changing back this young
man's name is Jamar normally you're not
allowed to touch the students like this
when they're in human form
but uh when they're capped we just have
at it
Sports
everybody loves Sportsman everybody the
hallways are a Bluster with the
conversation of awkwardness half a team
is Mack here riding mops we got two
little [ __ ] on Swiffer Lester
when all is said and done uh the average
chlortho student uh said this mother
sometimes the kids think it's cute to
turn themselves into a rat sneak into my
office play a little joke on me who is
that Tyrone is that is that no that's an
actual rat
[Applause]
[Music]
hey man how you doing there you guys got
bow and arrows yeah
oh yeah oh that's it yeah there it is
there that'll do it that's gonna do it
yep where the arrows at
yeah you guys got admitty's we don't
carry fireworks damn you have uh you
have something else that's explosive
that I could tape to the end of an arrow
we have shotgun shells but I feel I have
to ask are you planning to attach those
to arrows and use them as a weapon what
no what are you crazy
what if I shot to explosive arrows to a
window to break them open
sir I feel like I have to ask you what
you're planning to use these for hold on
I'm not planning to do anything I'm just
just Christmas shopping I'm getting you
got zip lines nope but you got like
Hooks and anchors and cables we got some
of those things but I do not recommend
manufacturing your own zip line oh I'm
not doing that no
let's say somebody was manufacturing
their own zip line do you think if they
had busted some windows open on a
building somehow then fired the zip line
off a bow and arrow and it attached to
the wall of said building that they
could just ride there's a blind into the
building
I have no idea sir whatever you're
planning on doing please don't do it I'm
not I'm not doing anything I'm just
doing some Christmas shopping I'm trying
to get it out of the way you know bow
and arrows from her nephew the zip lines
for my
grandmother
Etc and whatnot you know what I'm saying
there it's nothing no big deal speaking
of other things do you guys have just
the top hair off of a knight in armor
first of all it's called the suit of
armor oh yep that's it that's right
that's what I meant to say we have one
but it's sold complete set yep yep yep
yeah well the person is four they only
need to they don't need to they just
need the top half they don't need the
legs well what if somebody was shooting
at you what were the chances you think
they'd try to shoot your legs I feel
like I have to tell you that a suit of
armor will not deflect bullets
I'll take my church
with Christmas
brings me uh to my next question do you
guys have roller skates I think we have
a pair around let me ask you a question
how fast do you think you have to be
going on roller skates you get past a
couple of armor guards and still be
going fast enough to smash through a
safe door one of those big Bank saves no
I don't know yeah yeah
uh hey you guys got one of those you
know it's one of those big bags with a
dollar sign on the side of it okay
you're gonna shoot Arrows with shotgun
shells attached to them to a bank window
to blow out the glass then you're gonna
shoot a zip line through that window and
you're gonna slide on into the hallway
you're going to be wearing roller skates
so you can just skate on past the armed
guards who will be shooting at you and
you're going to hope that they both
won't hit your legs and if they are
aiming at your torso the suit of
medieval armor will deflect the bullets
then you're going to hope to gather
enough speed to burst through the big
bank vault at the end of the hallway
where you're going to collect the money
in a cartoon money bag
well no understand uncle's wine for
Christmas and I uh I think I'll take my
business elsewhere Merry Christmas
it's April
[Music]